millions of film fans hold special
places in their hearts for Forrest Jenny
Lieutenant Dan and the rest of the
unforgettable characters of Forrest Gump
but what happened to the ensemble in the
years since 1994 we've taken a look back
to find out what these stars have been
up to let's start with the obvious Tom
Hanks already an oscar-winning megastar
when he played Forrest Gump hasn't
exactly vanished from view Hanks
executive produced the Emmy winning HBO
miniseries Band of Brothers played to
American heroes and captain Phillips and
Sully
voiced a neurotic cowboy and Pixar's Toy
Story franchise and also became the star
of Saturday Night Live's most memorable
baffling Halloween skit the
award-winning actor also remains half of
one of Hollywood's most long-standing
marriages with wife Rita Wilson with the
two having been married since 1988 he's
gained a reputation as one of the
loveliest people in Hollywood and he has
a hobby of collecting vintage
typewriters Robin Wright was hardly an
unknown when she scored her role in
Forrest Gump her role on the daytime
drama Santa Barbara had already earned
her tons of fans and she also starred in
cult fairytale favorite The Princess
Bride but for whatever reason Wright
spent the next two decades flying way
under the radar it's surprising that the
role that made her a household name is
one she landed at the age of 46 the
ambitious brilliant Claire underwood on
Netflix is house of cards off screen
right has become an outspoken advocate
and spokesperson for por la femme a
sleepwear company that educates and
employs women in conflict regions around
the world most of the main folks in
forrest gump have gone on to long and
storied acting careers but Michael
Connor Humphries is an exception after
what could have been a breakout
performances young Forrest Humphries
instead quit acting entirely and took a
different path joining the army he
served four years as an infantry soldier
with his service including an 18-month
tour of duty in Iraq according to an
interview with the Daily Mail he tried
to keep his brief stint in Hollywood a
secret but it didn't take long for his
fellow service members to figure it out
and give him the nickname of Gump
Humphreys made a belated return to
acting in the 2010s
playing a soldier in the 2011 indie film
pathfinders in the company of strangers
and he also scored a role on the 29
tene TV series nights end in a 2015
interview he was said to be living back
in his birthplace of independence
Mississippi where he pursued a college
degree in international relations that's
Hannah Hall's biggest contribution to
the cultural zeitgeist at the age of
nine she became known for shouting what
became Forrest Gump's most quotable line
but she's also worked regularly ever
since as a teen she scored roles in
Sofia Coppola 's The Virgin Suicides and
the 2007 remake of Halloween and in more
recent years she appeared in guest roles
on Criminal Minds and masters of sex
despite having grown up a lot since her
Forrest Gump performance Hall is still
occasionally recognized on the street by
sharp-eyed fans who asked her to repeat
her famous catchphrase but she said she
doesn't know how to do that Alabama
accent anymore so if you happen to see
her just don't ask Sally Field was
already a multiple Oscar winner and a
Lister when she played the tenacious
matriarch of the Gump family her legacy
as an actor was rock-solid no matter
what she did after Forrest Gump but
where's she now after spending several
years as a Primetime Emmy award-winning
guest star on ER she joined the ABC
drama brothers and sisters for which she
won another Emmy she also turned up in
the role of Aunt May in the amazing
spider-man movies opposite Andrew
Garfield in 2017 she earned critical
acclaim for playing the challenging role
of Amanda Wingfield in a Broadway
revival of The Glass Menagerie while
2018 saw her take on a key supporting
role in the Netflix series maniac
basically she's keeping plenty busy as
she rounds the corner on their seventh
decade in Sally Fields storied career
Forrest Gump is just a footnote after
his remarkable turn as Forrest Gump's
BFF Bubba Blue Micheal T Williams son
has stayed busy in Hollywood
consistently working smaller parts on
the big and small screens among his more
prominent appearances are a regular role
unjustified that spanned three seasons a
role in the political thriller series 24
and more Williamson seems to specialize
in playing police officers and military
men although he did run afoul of the law
when he played baby-o in the cult
favorite Conair and don't think he's
given up serious award season fare in
2016 he was part of the cast in the
oscar-nominated fence it's directed by
Denzel Washington on
some of his co-stars Williamson has
fully embraced his legacy as a Forrest
Gump cast member on Instagram he's even
celebrated his characters signature
seafood obsession with shrimp Saturday
in which he posts shrimp elated selfies
and solicits pictures of shrimp from
fans around the globe Gary Sinise's had
no shortage of high profile projects
since Forrest Gump including repeated
reunions of Tom Hanks the two appeared
together in Apollo 13 in 1996 and again
in The Green Mile in 1999 on the small
screen Sinise's found a comfortable home
in primetime procedural drama playing
detective Mac Taylor and the CSI
franchise from 2004 through 2013 then
taking over Anna lead role in the
Criminal Minds franchise in 2016 in a
fitting turn considering his military
experience in Forrest Gump Sinise has
become a prominent supporter of American
servicemembers
he's lended his talents as a narrator to
various military documentaries entertain
troops with the Lieutenant Dan band and
created his own philanthropic
organization the Gary Sinise foundation
to support service members once they're
back home on US soil
Sinise has also been one of the few
openly republican celebrities in
hollywood founding a group for
conservative actors known as the Friends
of Abe in 2004 and supporting John
McCain's 2008 presidential campaign
however he disassociated himself from
the organization prior to the 2016
election and his online presence makes
it clear that apart from acting his real
priority is supporting the troops the
sleazy principal who admitted Forrest to
the public school system in exchange for
a roll in the hay with mrs. Gump will
forever be remembered for his awkward
well this but when it comes to this
actor you're more likely to recognize
him from the TV roles that followed from
2005 through 2010 Anderson was a series
regular unlost in the role of the
kind-hearted crash survivor Bernard and
if you didn't catch him in that you
might know him as the cold-heartedly
Paxton unjustified but as ubiquitous as
he is on screen the actor keeps a low
profile off-camera he's been married to
the same woman since 1985 is the father
of twins and in his spare time he likes
to write mysteries in short Anderson has
gone on from Forrest Gump to become what
seems like the lifestyle
of an average retired dad except that
he's also one of the hardest-working
character actors of his generation if
you've seen Forrest Gump you'll
recognize a fameux Emil ah me as the
frothing drill sergeant who complimented
Force intelligence sort of the drill
sergeant role was only a bit part for
O'Neil ami who was already a Hollywood
veteran when Forrest Gump was made Emil
ami has appeared in multiple projects
every year dating all the way back to
1990 most recently he held a major role
in true detective and appeared as the
mayor of district 11 in the Hunger Games
Catching Fire and despite his busy work
schedule Emil ami also helps to run
Hosea feed the hungry and Atlanta based
charitable organization designed to
combat homelessness and food scarcity
it's practically the end of the movie
before he appears on screen but he's
there before he saw dead people Haley
Joel Osment made his big screen debut in
the tiny role of Forrest Junior needless
to say it was a good jumping off point
for Osmonds career he went on to become
a Hollywood icon at the age of nine
thanks to his breakout performance in
the sixth sense he took a break to
attend college and while his celebrity
status has receded he's not hurting for
work
he recently reprised his role as Sora in
the third Kingdom Hearts game and
continues to appear in smaller parts in
movies TV and other weird projects
character actor Jeffrey Blake portrayed
the loathsome Wesley Jenny's abusive bad
news boyfriend he'd already appeared in
dozens of movies and TV shows before
Forrest Gump and he went right back to
that hustle after filming his part you
may have seen him in one of his many
short stints on shows like renegade NYPD
Blue multiple CSI series Criminal Minds
and Grimm and while they played enemies
on-screen Blake and Hanks must have
gotten along just fine in real life
Blake went on to film small parts for
Hanks Apollo 13 and cast away when
Siobhan Fallon Hogan appeared as the
hard nut to crack bus driver in Forrest
Gump she'd just finished some small but
memorable work into comedy institutions
she'd been a cast member on Saturday
Night Live for its 17th season in 1991
and 92 and had a recurring role on
Seinfeld as Tina
Elaine's weird roommate Fallon Hogan has
played many small parts since but she's
also a frequent muse of provocative
filmmaker laws von trier but while she
still works as an
she left Hollywood behind long ago
choosing instead to live in suburban New
Jersey with her family when a nearly
grown forest gets chased by a bunch of
bullies in a pickup truck he's so fast
he manages to outrun them earning the
attention of legendary University of
Alabama football coach Paul Bear Bryant
Forrest secures a sports scholarship and
becomes a reliable all-american
playmaker who's eventually given the
chance to meet President John F Kennedy
John F Kennedy may appear in the movie
thanks to special effects but Bear
Bryant is played by a flesh-and-blood
actor named Sonny Shroyer it's nowhere
near Schroyer 'he's most famous work
though
prior to his Forrest Gump par he played
deputy sheriff eNOS on the popular TV
series The Dukes of Hazzard Schroyer was
so likable in the role that he got his
own spinoff series simply called eNOS in
1980 Schroyer was nearly 60 years old
when forrest gump was filmed and his
career has understandably slowed down a
bit in the years since he tended toward
movies with ties to the American South
including Ray a love song for Bobby long
and multiple adaptations of John Grisham
novels when force heads to New York City
to check on his old friend Lieutenant
Dan he finds that his former commanding
officer isn't doing well he's found
living in squalor spending most of his
time drinking and cavorting with two
women of questionable repute long limbs
Leonor and cunning Carla Marla
cigarettes the actress who played Leonor
is presumably a lot nicer than she comes
across on screen horoscope marked her
first role in a major movie and in its
wake she's had a long career as a
character actor she's popped up in TV
shows like Seinfeld damages and The Good
Wife and made multiple appearances on
different Law & Order series she also
appeared in movies such as the station
agent and the crude comedy roadtrip in
which she was credited as playing a
sperm bank nurse Hey acting isn't always
glorious sometimes you're in a gross out
movie
and sometimes you're in the cast of a
beloved Best Picture laughs is a box of
chocolates forest you never know what
you're gonna get check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]